joining us now Wall Street Journal's
Kimberly straw so she was the first
journalist to expose this huge scandal
nearly two weeks ago that in fact the
FBI used an informant to spy on the
Trump campaign she joins us as well as
Fox News contributor jason Chaffetz you
know I love the Wall Street Journal in
their comments today in their editorial
Kimberly I thought it was devastating
and also the calls on the Obama
administration they callin on Obama what
did he know when did he know it and now
noona is saying Kimberly there might be
a second spy yeah this is really
important first of all for people to
remember that the Department of Justice
which is now out there hinting and
various partisans like Adam Schiff that
somehow congressman newness and others
are responsible for blowing this source
the Department of Justice leaked all of
these details to friendly news media
sources everything short of this guy's
name and his social security number and
go and just so that they could get ahead
of this and spin it the way they wanted
to because they knew the noose was
tightening and they'd probably be forced
to put out these documents and this is
the other important part too is well
none of us have really had enough
information on yet is we know a lot
about what the FBI did although still
not enough what we don't know though is
what the political side of this
operation knew we know Clinton's
campaign had this dossier too who else
had it in the Obama administration and
what other agencies were involved in
efforts to go after the Trump campaign
prior to the FBI's claim of its official
start of its investigation IIIi will all
say it so I don't want to bring up
former congressman Chaffetz Schiff is
the biggest liar and propagandist on
television almost as bad as fake news
CNN and conspiracy TV MSNBC bigger
points here the FBI paid this guy we've
all known his name for a long time this
is not they've leaked it they're the
ones that did it but paying this guy
money and maybe a second spy and I don't
believe they're gonna hand over the
documents if they can get away with it
congressman Chaffetz you requested some
of those very same information well over
a year ago and
never been forthcoming yeah there is a
subpoena we issued in 2016 for all the
documents that we wanted to see the
Inspector General can get these
documents if he hasn't already I hope
he's already gathered to gather them up
I think the deep state is understanding
that the truth is going to surface and
that's why they're leaking this
information to friendly news sources to
put their own spin on it I think Kim's
Drossel has done some of the best
reporting on that but I got to tell you
you have an attorney general in Jeff
Sessions who's there in name only he's
worthless and he have rose rod
Rosenstein who's there with an oxygen
mask
he's totally conflicted and I'm excited
with some members in the house are going
to do tomorrow I think there's a group
of 5 members actually put it put forward
our resolution is a vicious temper and
right now is on edge every day screaming
at people have you heard that
congressman mantova there I mean it's
amazing if you look at what rod
Rosenstein is arguing and then you look
at the Democrats like Adam Jim this
political hack that is just desperate
not shiftless sure you come out yeah I
mean he doesn't want to have truth come
out he doesn't want it excels what's
going on there that probably answers
part of the gang of eight he likes
working all that information and I agree
with Devin I agree with congressman
Chaffetz you've done a great job
Kimberly that's word look the other
thing this has got to be declassified
Congress needs to see it first but then
every one of us needs the president can
do that correct yes demand they turn him
over now correct yep yes the president
he's the President of the United States
roughly constitutionally elected person
and he can declassify it now do i I
would say to the president do it now do
not wait 18 months for the IG to
investigate with 500 people and then
we'll find out later they'll they'll do
everything they can to spin it why the
leak thank you all